a Spanish sex product company is
creating the library of orgasm sounds
I'm not making this up check this
article out yes they're making the idea
the library of orgasm sounds the idea is
to make a database of real orgasm sounds
available so that people can feel
comfortable with whatever sound they
make at that at that moment
what are you doing there you want to
make a donation to the orgasm sound
library who are you I'm the sound guy
for the National orgasm Library of Spain
oh that's why I was just mentioning that
in the monologue here how'd you get here
so fast
I'm really fast okay alrighty come on an
orgasm No
[Applause]
alright alright fine fine fine fine fine
excellent that's what's good good pretty
much what it is with me yeah you want to
do another one
no I do not want to do another one
that's it alright get my hand everybody
anyway as I was saying it's brave to
stick one okay it's your turn sweetheart
our guy sure I'd be honored okay in
three two
Kasdan yeah all right well I think that
guy got what he needed so I think we're
okay now we could vote you for sure okay
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
sir what you're doing is incredibly
inappropriate this is a live studio
audience that doesn't seem like science
to me you just seem like a pervert with
a boom mic all right
do you even know that this the name of
the laboratory are working for sure sort
of the Institute for making people make
noises for me to listen to later yeah I
think we're gonna move the show along if
you don't mind okay we have a great show
tonight's stars of the new Netflix movie
the do-over Adam Sandler David Spade
joining us
[Applause]
both of you at once please
[Applause]
creator and star of the Comedy Central
series another period comedian Natasha
Leggero is here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you